mes chers collègues je vous souhaite le
bonjour monsieur le ministre nous sommes
vraiment heureux de vous accueillir
parce que c'est un rendez-vous que nous
avions programmé puis les aléas des
emplois du temps on fait que c'est
aujourd'hui que nous nous retrouvons
donc je lisais on a
utile aujourd'hui une légère
perturbation dans les mobilités
et certains collègues ont deux ou trois
séances de travaux aujourd'hui donc ne
vous étonnez pas si un peu de
va-et-vient mais en tout cas je crois
que nous sommes tous extrêmement heureux
de vous accueillir et je voulais vous en
remercier puisque votre sujet
enfin le sujet dont vous avez la charge
et au cœur des préoccupations des
collectivités et je pense aujourd'hui
plus que jamais alors que le sujet était
déjà fort préoccupant et nous avons eu
déjà une séquence politique de la ville
à la délégation puisque nous avions eu
le plaisir d'entendre nos collègues
Dominique Estrosi ça sonne
Viviane Artigalas nous présenter
l'excellent rapport qu'elles avaient
commis si je puis dire qui a été signé
avec Valérie l'État et qu'il s'appelait
très justement la politique de la ville
un tremplin pour les habitants parce que
le sujet pour nous tous au final quand
on est élu c'est de permettre que chacun
puisse bénéficier d'un tremplin pour
s'accomplir et s'émanciper dans la vie
et nous savons que la politique de la
ville allait éminemment partenariale et
si les tailles jouent un rôle essentiel
elle concerne de près les collectivités
qui sont très acteurs et qui ont déjà
d'ailleurs essayez
d'expérimenter quelques éléments de
décentralisation j'en dirai un mot tout
à l'heure donc nous aimerions monsieur
le ministre que vous puissiez nous faire
un point sur les contrat de ville
qui sont en quelque sorte en prorogation
est-ce que
monsieur le ministre le principe de
contractualisation qui existe
aujourd'hui pourraient évoluer 20
principes de délégation complète de
compétences pour les collectivités qui
le souhaiteraient et je donnerai un
exemple par la mémoire c'est un exemple
breton quand l'aéroport
Notre-Dame-des-Landes avait été
abandonné il y a vu un pacte breton qui
incluait à volait logement notamment sur
le logement privé et le dispositif
d'investissement locatif et la Bretagne
avait donc expérimenté la possibilité de
gérer à l'échelle de l'espace régional
l'enveloppe
d'investissement locatif dont bénéficier
les deux métropoles de façon à prendre
en compte des particularités de
situation parce qu'on peut être en
dehors de la zone à avoir de la zone B
des zones de tension donc je sais que
aujourd'hui la loi permet de enfin en
quelque sorte de pérenniser enfin la
pérennisation comme l'éternité on sait
pas combien de temps ça dure mais en
tout cas de pouvoir élargir le
dispositif et le consolider
où en est-on des nouveaux contrats de
villes il y aura-t-il des des
innovations alors vous avez installé
vous allez sûrement nous en parler une
commission nationale participation
citoyenne des quartiers pour réfléchir
aux futurs de la politique de la ville
est-ce que cette commission travaillera
sur les contrats de ville comment les
collectivités ils seront associés
institutionnellement vous avez également
fixé quatre priorités me semble-t-il
pour les nouveaux contrats l'emploi à
travers un soutien à l'entrepreneuriat
et le développement du salariat la
transition écologique
par le biais du programme de
renouvellement urbain et la mobilisation
du fond vert et l'émancipation pour tous
j'en parlais dans mon introduction grâce
à l'éducation l'accès à la culture au
sport et enfin la sécurité la
tranquillité donc on voit là qui est un
écosystème
vertueux si nous pouvons parler un peu
nos en serions heureux toujours sur ces
contrats de ville quelle est leur
articulation avec le projet quartier
2030 qui a été évoqué par le chef de
l'État
il y a eu d'ailleurs sur ce sujet une
réunion interminée ministérielle sur le
9 février dernier
ici encore monsieur le ministre comment
les collectivités seront associées et
enfin le 15 février dernier vous avez
présenté les grandes lignes de la
nouvelle géographie prioritaire au
préfet sous-préfet chargé de la
politique de la ville pouvez-vous nous
dire quelques mots sur la façon dont
celle-ci va évoluer sachant que vous le
fait que de nombreux mères sont
confrontés à des difficultés budgétaires
à cause de la crise énergétique et de
l'inflation et que je rappelle que le
surcoût pour l'ensemble des
collectivités de la crise énergétique
c'est 15 milliards d'euros ces
difficultés concernent aussi et
peut-être encore plus les villes qui ont
d'importants quartiers relevant de la
politique de la vie est-ce qu'on a un
point particulier sur cette situation et
nous rapporteur aimé pointeaux et Sonia
de la provolté j'ai une liste de courses
pour Monsieur le Ministre voilà mes
collègues en auront beaucoup donc nos
rapporteurs Sonia de la propretérémie
pointron rendu en 2022 un rapport
important et très intéressant
d'évaluation des politiques de
revitalisation des centres-villes et des
centres baux et à cette occasion est
revenu à plusieurs reprises
l'idée ou la conviction que la
coordination NCT en rue était peut-être
savoir extrêmement perfectible le sujet
de la coordination des différents
acteurs et intervenants est un vrai
sujet pour les collectivités locales
enfin je regarde mon collègue
Jean-Michel Houlgate on a parlé tout à
l'heure
des conseils de quartier la
participation citoyenne et sûrement un
point fort de la politique de la ville
et donc avec mon collègue Jean-Michel
houlga nous avons commis un rapport
après les différentes élections
nationales et locales ou le constat
était celui de la gravation de
l'abstention et nous nous sommes
interrogés à comment on fait de la
politique autrement en essayant
d'intéresser ou de réenchanter nos
concitoyens et nous avons appelé ce
rapport la démocratie implicative
c'est-à-dire comment on invite le
citoyen à faire et non seulement à dire
il nous est remonté alors que les vous
conseille citoyen qui sont et qui ont
été voulu comme ça une pièce maîtresse
de la participation des habitants et à
raison peuvent s'essouffler donc dans
notre rapport nous avions proposé de
mobiliser les élus locaux et les
conseiller citoyens autour de formation
commune c'est à dire on avait parfois
l'impression que le Conseil citoyen
c'est soufflé il avait l'impression que
ces idées n'étaient pas intégrées qu'il
était à côté de ceux qui relevaient de
la démocratie représentative ce qui est
vrai mais sans doute faut-il construire
comme l'ont dit aujourd'hui un peu de
commun autour de ça et peut-être
notamment la formation des temps de
dialogue sur sur des projets permettrait
de les dynamiser donc il a d'ailleurs
été indiqué que la mission de la
commission nationale participation
citoyenne des quartiers
porterait sur les modalités d'expression
une participation des habitants des qpv
confirmant ainsi ce sentiment
d'essoufflement que nous avions ressenti
qu'est-il attendu de cette réflexion et
bien j'ai épuisé ma liste de courses
dans un premier temps monsieur minet je
vous renouvelle mes remerciements je
vous laisse la parole et je ne doute pas
que mes collègues auront de nombreuses
efforts pertinentes questions à votre
attention merci
merci madame la Présidente chère
Françoise mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs permettez-moi de vous
présenter un propos liminaire qui ira
au-delà de vos questions chers Françoise
Le propos liminaire reprendra une partie
de vos questions et puis ensuite j'y
répondrai plus précisément donc ça fait
maintenant 9 mois que j'ai été nommé au
gouvernement et effectivement cette
occasion et pour moi l'occasion de faire
un point un premier point d'étape et
j'en suis très heureux et je présente à
nouveau mes excuses de les deux reports
dû à des impondérables de de calendrier
je crois même des convocations en
conseil des ministres qu'on a ministre
délégué c'est rare donc on y va à chaque
fois bien évidemment mais voilà je vais
vous faire un point sur les grands axes
de ma feuille de route tant sur le
logement que sur la politique de la
ville et je crois et vous l'avez dit dès
votre introduction que le portefeuille
qui est le mien est un portefeuille qui
doit particulièrement s'articuler avec
avec les collectivités vous le savez je
le sais les élus sont des partenaires
essentiels qu'il s'agisse de la
politique du logement comme celle de la
politique de la ville et les
collectivités ont donc toute leur place
toute leur part à prendre dans cette
politique tout à la fois du logement et
de la ville tournée vers les territoires
on va je vais commencer par vous parler
un peu de la politique du logement qui
doit reposer je crois et je pense que on
le partage tous sur un dialogue
important entre l'État le maire la
collectivité locale bien évidemment
aussi les intercommunalités cette
politique du logement doit répondre à
une situation qui disons-le en ce moment
n'est pas bonne ma mission celle du
gouvernement et de faire en sorte que le
logement ne soit pas et j'ai déjà
employé l'expression la bombe sociale de
demain et pour cela nous devons
travailler étroitement avec les élus
locaux qui sont les meilleures
connaisseurs de leur territoire
d'abord parlons du logement social je
crois important sur ce sujet de pouvoir
maintenir un dialogue permanent avec nos
élus et avec nos maires en particulier
président d'intercommunalité bien sûr
aussi je souhaite ainsi ouvrir les
champs des questions des attributions
vous le savez à l'évolution dans une
gestion en flux va en principe les
simplifier et c'est heureux pour les
demandeurs mais ne doit pas au contraire
donner l'impression aux élus locaux de
s'en éloigner et donc je ne souhaite pas
et je souhaite que cette gestion en flux
soit une opportunité et pas un obstacle
et qu'elle ne doit pas déconnecter les
élus de leurs habitants et je souhaite
travailler avec vous pour qu'un maire
puisse accomplir son mandat en
attribuant des logements sociaux suivant
sa vision de la ville pour laquelle il a
été élu mais bien évidemment dans le
respect de principe si je veux dire
républicain et et les principes que
l'ensemble des financeurs
doivent pouvoir lui demander vous le
savez je suis aussi également très
attaché au respect de la loi et ces rues
en tout cas dans les communes où c'est
possible
quand on émerge et je l'ai été on doit
faire en sorte de loger les personnes
qui vivent et qui travaillent dans nos
villes pour y parvenir il y a les
contrats de mixité sociale que je
souhaite voir signer avec un maximum de
communes volontaires c'est le sens du
bilan trial qui a été lancé depuis peu
afin de faire un point complet de la
situation le deuxième sujet c'est celui
de réconcilier notre pays et ses
habitants avec l'acte de construire
nommé ont une responsabilité centrale en
la matière nous ne devons de regarder
collectivement la réalité en face quelle
est-elle la réalité c'est d'abord de
constater qu'il est de plus en plus
difficile d'obtenir des permis de
construire notamment en zone tendue la
réalité c'est aussi de constater qu'il
n'y a pas assez de logements libres
comme socio produits dans ces zones
tendues alors que nous le savons tous
les besoins sont importants même de plus
en plus important
alors oui il faut réussir à réconcilier
notre pays avec l'acte de construire et
ça nous y arriverons seulement avec
l'engagement des élus
vous le savez il y a un conseil national
de la refondation du logement et il
formulera de nombreuses propositions en
ce sens pour y arriver je veux également
accompagner le chantier d'une
décentralisation efficace comme la
souhaiter le président de la République
et des discussions ont d'ores et déjà
commencé avec les associations d'élus et
je trouvais aussi avec vous donc le
chemin pour redonner aux élus et aux
Français l'envie de construire des
logements pour tous pour le plus grand
nombre
bien évidemment dans la situation
écologique de notre pays il faut tout
construire plus mais il faut aussi
construire mieux la dynamique est en
cours les promoteurs les architectes les
entreprises du bâtiment travaux publics
sont en train de transformer en
profondeur leur activité pour répondre à
cette ambition environnementale et aux
exigences de la re 20 20 j'étais hier un
salon du bois dans la construction à
Lille et on voit comment l'ensemble des
promoteurs des architectes des
entreprises avec le ministre de
l'Agriculture pour créer cette filière
bois prend en compte
cet impératif de construire plus et de
construire mieux
donne un cadre réglementaire ambitieux
en portant dans la construction neuve
plusieurs objectifs des objectifs de
sobriété énergétiques vous le savez des
objectifs de sortie des énergies
fossiles et des objectifs de diminution
de l'impact carbone cette accélération
dans la construction de la ville durable
que le gouvernement porte elle se
concrétise également par le fond vert
ce fond de 2 milliards d'euros pour les
collectivités locales c'est un
engagement fort pour accélérer la
transition écologique de nos villes de
nos territoires et cela fonctionne
puisque vous le savez déjà 150 projets
ont été
déclarésoréat de ce fond pour
accompagner les collectivités dans leurs
projets
pour entrer dans le fond il faut faire
des propositions pour adapter la ville
au changement climatique pour régénérer
des fiches urbaines le fond vert a pris
en son sein et à pérenniser le fond
friche qui avait très bien marché dans
le plan de relance il permet aussi aux
collectivités locales de rénover des
équipements publics et en particulier
les écoles même s'il y aura un plan
école qui sera présenté dans quelques
semaines c'est du concret et surtout je
le rappelle c'est un fond à destination
des élus locaux qui sont les mieux
placés pour porter des projets de
transition écologique adaptées à leur
territoire
il faut aussi rénover massivement en
lien avec les collectivités c'est une
propriété une priorité très claire de
notre gouvernement et le président de la
République l'a rappelé en ciblant la
transition écologique parmi les axes
principaux sur lesquels il nous faut
accélérer concrètement pour nos citoyens
je le redire avec force parce que les
discours qui consistent à dire que rien
ne va ne font qu'en tâcher la
crédibilité de cette politique publique
essentielle les résultats de ma prime
rénove et de France Renov sont concrets
ils sont là ma prime rénov c'est la
réussite de la massification des travaux
de rénovation il y a eu 1,5 millions de
projets soutenus depuis 2020 plus de 160
000 rénovations globales
et donc bien au-delà des chiffres qui
ont été indiqués par moment ce bilan est
bon ce qui nous empêche pas bien
évidemment de vous dire qu'il faut faire
mieux
pour faire mieux et plus de rénovation
globale il faut faire mieux et plus de
rénovation globale notamment dans
l'habitat collectif et vous êtes un
certain nombre à connaître les
problématiques de l'habitat collectif il
est indispensable d'inventer de
nouvelles aides pour les copropriétés
notamment et il faut continuer à
améliorer fluidifier le parcours des
usagers faciliter leurs projets il y a
encore trop d'usagers qui viennent vers
vous les parlementaires pour nous dire
que le dossier est long et prend du
temps à être répondu mais nous allons et
nous y travaillons avec avec la nappe
pour aller améliorer ces situations
pour amplifier nos efforts par la mise
en place mise en oeuvre pardon d'une
trajectoire crédible de sortie des
énergies fossiles par un meilleur
accompagnement des ménages par le
service public France Renov j'en ai
parlé par un parcours plus lisible et
incitatif avec des subventions plus
importantes pour aller vers une
rénovation globale et pas une rénovation
au gestes bien évidemment par la
poursuite du soutien aux copropriété
j'en ai déjà parlé et levé les freins
qu'il rencontre en matière d'information
en matière d'accompagnement en matière
de gouvernance vous le savez gérer une
copropriété c'est difficile avoir une un
quorum en assemblée générale c'est pas
toujours facile faire voter les travaux
ça allait encore moins il faut je le
crois retoiletter tout cela et
évidemment diminuer autant que possible
reste à charge pour que les travaux de
la copropriété soit soit votées c'est le
travail que nous menons avec Lana mais
aussi avec les institutions
bancaire pour que l'accès auprès
notamment les co-prés à taux zéro soit
possible pour financer le reste à charge
et déclencher l'acte du vote en
assemblée générale et donc les travaux
ensuite il faut bien évidemment
continuer et c'est une urgence à
structurer la filière puisque pour
pouvoir avancer il faut que des gens
puissent faire ses travaux et c'est un
chantier que nous menons avec la FFB et
la CAPEB et le ministre
Bruno Le Maire notamment lors des
Assises du bâtiment
nous continuons et nous continuerons à
concerter avec l'ensemble de ces leviers
et les collectivités locales ont bien
sûr un rôle clé à jouer à ce titre une
concertation pour co-construire le cadre
pérenne et simplifier de portage de
financement de France Renov est en cours
y compris dans les dans le chantier lié
à la décentralisation pour voir quelles
sont les meilleurs outils
je vais vous parler maintenant de la
politique de la ville comme vous m'y
avait invité madame la Présidente et
faire nos quartiers de demain avec avec
nos élites avec nos élus lié la
politique de la ville et du logement
comme l'ont décidé de le faire le
président de la République et la
première ministre à travers
le ministère qui est le mien permet je
crois d'avoir des résultats forts dans
nos quartiers pour que les habitants des
quartiers se sentent pleinement citoyens
de la République
quartier 2030 c'est une ambition des
outils et une méthode j'y reviendrai il
y a pas de séparation entre quartiers
2030 et la politique de la ville et les
futurs contraintes ville quartier 2030
c'est une ambition qui nous porte dans
un calendrier qui est à la fois de moyen
terme mais mais atteignable et
d'ailleurs les nouveaux contrats de
ville seront sous-titrés engagement
quartier 2030 pour bien montrer le lien
entre entre ces projets et ce chapeau
général que souhaite le président de la
République dans l'ambition qu'il a fixé
pour les quartiers populaires autour
d'un certain nombre d'enjeux que vous
avez rappelé la jeunesse l'accès à
l'emploi notamment à travers
l'entrepreneuriat la rénovation urbaine
la tranquillité et la sécurité
l'éducation notamment
quartier 2030 ce sont des outils de la
politique de la ville rénovée et c'est
le travail que j'ai lancé au service de
la reconnaissance des habitants de leurs
besoins et de leurs paroles c'est pour
ça que j'ai lancé début mars la
commission présidée par Mohamed pour
repenser la participation citoyenne
s'assurer que la parole des habitants
irrigue notre action je souhaite
vraiment que les futurs contrats de
ville engagement 2030 soit coécrique
co-construit avec les habitants des
quartiers et surtout qu'on est je crois
enfin même si tous les ministres de la
ville l'ont probablement dit avant moi
une capacité à construire un projet sur
mesure en fonction du quartier la
politique de la ville dans le quartier
Pissevin à anime pour prendre un exemple
qui est cher au sénaté en bourguin ou un
quartier de Nice ou de Clichy-sous-Bois
et bien ne doit pas forcément embrasser
les mêmes enjeux certains quartiers
veulent pouvoir travailler sur les
questions de la petite enfance d'autres
celles de l'accès à l'emploi d'autres
veulent faire tout ça en même temps même
si nous allons donner des axes qui sont
des axes assez naturels et bien je
souhaite que que chaque territoire les
élus les habitants avec l'aide des
préfets puissent construire leur propre
contrat de ville engagement quartier
2030 en fonction des priorités qui se
seront les leurs et il n'y aura pas de
la part des préfets des refus ou des
demandes de revoir la copie parce que
parmi les quatre axes un axe a été pas
assez embrassé par le par le projet je
pense que les élus sont les meilleurs
connaisseurs de leur territoire et des
priorités qu'il souhaite fixées dans
dans le dans le contrat de ville et vous
l'avez dit
le le la commission de Mohamed mechmach
doit être une commission qui
l'expression de cette parole la
garantisse et puis nous aider à
réfléchir à ce que sera la participation
des habitants les conseils citoyens ont
joué un rôle là où ils en jouent encore
et bien il faut les préserver là où ils
ont besoin d'être étoilé retoilerons-le
vous le savez on est quelques-uns être
un peu maintenant des anciens je vais
pas dire des vieux des anciens de la
politique de la ville et de la
participation des habitants rien que le
nom conseil et rend les choses déjà
suspects de côté de nos habitants moi
j'ai des conseils citoyen dans lequel on
a tiré au sort des gens et d'un seul
coup le regard des habitants du quartier
sur eux alors qu'ils ont été tirés au
sort change donc soyons inventifs moi je
crois aux tables de quartier au
dispositif plus informel de
participation des habitants qui se
constituent autour d'un projet dans
lequel les habitants vont pouvoir
échanger sur ce projet parce que ce
projet les intéresse ils sont pour ils
sont contre ils ont envie de le faire
évoluer et puis une fois que ce projet
est sur les rails la table de quartier
peut continuer et s'intéresser à notre
projet des gens peuvent rentrer peuvent
sortir je pense que la la politique de
la ville et la participation des
habitants a besoin d'outils assez
souples qui s'adapte en fonction des
envies des habitants et c'est le sens je
crois de du travail que fera Mohamed et
la vingtaine de personnes qui
l'accompagnent dans cette commission une
commission qui comprend des experts des
élus des habitants des militants
associatifs et donc ce travail est en
route
depuis hier je crois les préfectures ont
reçu les nouvelles propositions de
cartographie de la géographie
prioritaire donc les nouveaux quartiers
en politique de la ville et là encore je
souhaite qu'il y ait de la souplesse et
que un travail
itératif se fasse cette fois-ci plutôt
entre les préfectures et les élus qui là
aussi sont les plus à même de connaître
leur territoire et de voir que dans un
endroit qui n'a pas été coché par
l'Insee dans le
carroyage et bien il y a besoin d'une
intervention de la politique de la ville
évitons les effets de bord les effets de
trottoir et ce travail doit commencer
dans les jours qui viennent puisque
maintenant les préfets ont tous reçu le
travail mené par par l'INSEE et c'était
l'objet de la réunion que j'ai menée
avec eux à la fois leur dire mon souhait
de cette grande prise en compte de la de
la parole des habitants dans les futurs
contrats de ville quartier 2030 et
ensuite de travailler avec les avec les
élus des villes et des intercommunalités
à définir la nouvelle le nouveau le
nouveau zonage
donc j'ai perdu mon fil mais c'est pas
grave je crois avoir dit l'essentiel en
termes de souplesse et donc l'idée c'est
d'avoir des contrats de ville engagement
quartier 2030 sur 3 ans et donc qui
embrasse le programme quartier 2030
puisque on signera les nouveaux contrats
de villes engagement quartier 2030 au
1er janvier 2024 et et le calendrier
sera tenu un programme de trois ans donc
24 27 27 30 et donc avec une clause de
revoyure si possible un maximum de
conventions plus réelle d'objectif pour
que et les collectivités locales et les
associations ne passent pas leur temps à
faire des demandes de subvention et les
services et que ce soit dans les villes
ou dans les préfectures ne passent pas
leur temps à faire des bilans etc mais
qu'on donne du temps qu'on donne du
temps aux déléguer du préfet notamment
qui joue un rôle très important dans les
quartiers en politique de la ville qu'on
donne du temps aux associations pour
faire leur travail et pas trop de
paperasserie c'est vraiment l'objectif
qui qui est le mien
voilà en quelques mots les grandes
lignes tant sur le logement que sur
la politique
de la ville si je reprends vos questions
madame la Présidente s'il y a des choses
auxquelles je n'ai pas répondu je vous
le redis
l'engagement du président de la
République quartier 2030 est un
engagement qui souhaite embrasser
l'ensemble de la politique dans les
quartiers populaires il est très
attentif à la question de
l'entrepreneuriat et de l'emploi dans
les quartiers il souhaite qu'on
développe cette question là il souhaite
aussi qu'on développe la place des
femmes à la fois dans l'engagement dans
l'entrepreneuriat mais aussi dans la
ville et dans leur quartier et donc il y
aura un certain nombre de d'actions et
de propositions sur ces sujets il nous a
demandé aussi de travailler sur la
question de la fracture numérique dans
les qui est populaire et
l'entrepreneuriat numérique et donc ce
chapeau viendra alimenter la politique
de la ville on travaille aussi à la
possibilité
d'avoir des politiques d'investissement
même dans les quartiers qui ne sont pas
en rue parce que c'est pas parce qu'on
n'est pas dans un quartier qui a été
défini dans un programme en rue qu'il
n'y a pas des choses à faire alors ça
doit se coordonner avec la dotation de
politique de la ville avec avec le fond
vert etc mais on a un souhait de pouvoir
détacher des moyens d'investissement
dans ces quartiers certains ont connu le
pnr4 par exemple qui était porté par la
rue qui permettait d'investir dans les
centres les quartiers de de centre-ville
notamment sur l'habitat ancien dégradé
et donc c'est tout ça qu'on essaye de
remettre en place dans le calendrier qui
sera respecté celui
d'un début de quartier 2030 au 1er au
1er janvier avec vraiment en tout cas
c'est mon souhait des programmes qui
seront co-écris avec les habitants les
associations les élus et vraiment à
l'échelle de de leur de leur quartier
j'ai dit sur j'ai essayé de vous
répondre je crois déjà sur la politique
de la ville la commission la commission
nationale la coordination anct en rue
alors je j'entends je il faut qu'on
regarde effectivement il y a plusieurs
coordination à améliorer je crois
même si ils y travaillent toujours
d'arrache-pied celle de lanrue et de
Lana en tout cas la visibilité et la
compréhension pour les pour les élus il
y a souvent dans des programmes en rue
des copropriétés dégradées des
copropriétés fragiles je ne parle pas
des des quartiers dans lequel on a un
programme en rue une horde d'intérêt
national dans lequel l'articulation est
encore plus plus complexe mais mais elle
est utile parce que on n'a jamais eu
d'outils plus puissant que que leur code
pour intervenir dans les copropriétés
dégradées la règle c'est si la copro
reste une copro c'est Lana si la
et recyclé en logements social c'est
plutôt la rue mais tout ça doit
s'articuler c'est vrai que la
méthodologie de la rue est une
méthodologie reconnue et c'est tant
mieux l'ancien président sans réjouit et
on le sait par exemple vous parliez
d'action cœur de ville
la moitié des programmes actions cœur de
ville existe dans des dans des villes où
il y a un programme en rue alors pas
forcément dans le programme Action cœur
de ville et c'est souvent des éléments
de réussite d'abord parce que ça permet
d'aider au logement un des freins
aujourd'hui très important dans les
programmes de renouvellement urbain
c'est le temps du relogement et ça c'est
lié aux questions de logement et de
production de logement on le voit
aujourd'hui un certain programme
dépassent les l'année de retard sur le
sur le relogement et c'est fâcheux ça
veut dire que un et c'est aussi le rôle
des intercommunalités les populations
des quartiers en renouvellement urbains
doivent être regardés avec
leurs problématiques aussi leurs
qualités et on ne doit pas dire que des
habitants des quartiers ne peuvent pas
être logés dans d'autres villes etc la
reconstitution de l'offre du logement
social et extrêmement important pour la
réussite des programmes en rue mais je
parle devant quelques experts donc ils
savent aussi bien que moi ce que je dis
et donc il faut qu'on travaille la
coordination entre la NCT et la rue
normalement est bonne mais mais si elle
est perfectible on y travaillera moi
j'ai fait partie de ceux qui ont
souhaité que que l'enru garde une forme
d'autonomie au moment de la création de
la NCT parce que elle a des spécificités
mais
le président de la rue et et membre du
conseil d'administration de la NCT et
participe à ces travaux mais mais
j'entends s'il y a des améliorations à
faire nous y travaillerons
je crois avoir balayé l'ensemble de vos
questions madame et présidente mais si
j'en ai oublié une je veux bien y
revenir
merci monsieur
de
réponse ou de votre intervention se
feront par le biais de qui sont merci en
tout cas monsieur le ministre vous avez
employé un mot que moi je n'ai pas osé
prendre à 7h qui n'est plus matinale
mais quand même celle de le mot de bombe
social vous avez parfaitement raison je
crois qu'ici nous partageons toute cette
crainte parce qu'il y a une conjonction
on va dire de
contraintes ou de situation qui nous
semblent
enfin mettre en très grande fragilité
l'exigence d'accès au logement
qui nous obsèvent tous et qui est
le vecteur d'intégration comme le
travail il y a deux phénomènes
aujourd'hui il y a celui à chaque fois
c'est phénomènes et ces contraintes
viennent de guider vertueuses
mais on dit aussi que l'enfer est pavé
de bonnes intentions et je pense qu'on
s'y retrouve un petit peu il y a
l'interdiction de logements dit passoire
thermique alors vous l'avez dit il y a
des aides considérables à la rénovation
mais nous savons que dans certaines
parties du territoire et parfois dans
des milieux ruraux notamment il y a des
logements qui font office de logement
social très souvent qui appartiennent à
des petits propriétaires
qui n'ont pas forcément ni la volonté ni
les moyens d'entreprendre des
rénovations donc on va se retrouver avec
une pénurie assez violente de logements
alors même que l'on sait que le logement
est un temps long et deuxième contrainte
des personnes encore osées ici prononcer
ce gros mot qui est celui du âne
alors le zan chose extrêmement vertueuse
enfin avec le zanne on frôle la santé si
j'ose dire sauf que comment voilà voilà
mais on va attendre la résurrection si
je finir parce que comment va-t-on
pouvoir
mais sérieusement et c'est pas une
provocation mais c'est vraiment une un
souci réel de tous les élus conjugués
cette contrainte de diminution de
logements passoire thermique d'une
manière très rapide alors même que la
contrainte d'usage arrive sincèrement je
pense qu'on est là au cœur de la manière
dont nous ne savons pas toujours dans
notre pays réfléchir en écosystème nous
réfléchissons de manière thématique nous
devons être vertu écologiquement mais
socialement il y aura un impact sur le
logement donc je vous avoue que si on
peut vous entendre là-dessus même si
frustré vous avez dû l'être un peu et
qui ont beaucoup de mal à expliquer leur
concitoyens qu'ils ont sur leur liste
d'attentes des gens qui habitent dans
leur ville qui sont des enfants de de
gens qui habitent dans la ville etc dans
des situations difficiles et que le
maire n'arrive pas à accorder de
logements
quand les préfets ont des possibilités
d'attribuer ces logements et je conteste
pas le le principe mais que tout ça se
fait d'une manière qui n'est pas
toujours très heureuse et qui en tout
cas met le maire en difficulté en
pression voilà vous êtes assez de
questions mais ce ministre charles-lévy
madame Estrosi satson Monsieur Bernard
buis je propose ces deux premières
questions et après Laurent burger Sonia
de la pauvreté Jean-Michel
Dominique qui est un peu madame logement
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre un certain nombre
de questions alors c'est pas ce que vous
avez dit mais moi j'attire votre
attention et sur un bruit ambiant quand
même qui ne cesse de monter comme quoi
dans notre besoin il n'y aurait plus
dans notre pays il n'y aurait plus
besoin de construire et de construction
neuve mais qu'il faudrait mettre
uniquement tous nos efforts sur la
rénovation énergétique des logements et
bien sûr sur la remise sur le marché des
logements vacants donc pour moi ce bruit
qu'on entend de plus en plus en tout cas
d'une certaine partie d'acteurs ou
d'opérateurs ou et particulièrement
inquiétant au regard de la crise du
logement que nous traversons donc bon
vous l'avez confirmé qu'il faut bien
qu'il y ait les deux piliers à la fois
la rénovation énergétique des logements
qui est un véritable défi et qu'il faut
porter de façon ambitieuse mais aussi le
besoin de construction neuf pour autant
c'est quand même une réalité aujourd'hui
qu'on entend de plus en plus je suis
très interrogé sur la
création des autorités organisatrices de
l'habitat qui ont été créés par la loi
3DS c'est un marqueur important pour les
politiques du logement pour les élus
locaux
sauf que aujourd'hui il faut faire en
sorte que ces aosh ne restent pas des
lettres mortes et justement qu'elle ne
demeure pas des structures vies d'effets
pour cela il faut réfléchir à un mode de
financement Haddock des autorités
organisatrices de l'habitat pour qu'elle
puisse véritablement développer une
compétence réelle et donc sur les
territoires alors je voudrais vous
interroger sur ce que vous pensez de la
proposition de la Fédération des offices
publics de l'habitat donc j'en suis
moi-même la secrétaire général donc je
la porte aussi comme j'ai porté les
aouages dans la loi 3DS je sais que
aujourd'hui cette proposition elle peut
faire débat je sais pas si vous en avez
pris connaissance qui serait de faire en
sorte que donc il y ait une partie de la
pecque qui viendrait donc
abonder les a oh comme on a des
autorités organisatrices de mobilité
avec un financement qui leur est propre
et donc cette partie de l'apex viendrait
donc abonder les aouaches pour leur les
doter d'un financement adoc propre et
qui leur permettent véritablement
d'exercer ses compétences dans les
territoires et en plus ça viendrait
améliorer l'efficience du lien qu'il y a
entre l'emploi et le logement au plus
près des besoins des entreprises et des
territoires j'ai beaucoup depuis de
nombreuses années plaider pour que
puisse être créé un véritable statut du
bailleur privé je sais que vous en avez
parlé et je crois savoir aussi que le
Conseil national de la refondation s'est
penché sur la création d'un statut du
bailleur privé alors peut-être tout le
monde entend pas la même chose par la
création d'un statut du bailleur privé
moi je vous les interroger sur le fait
de est-ce que vous concevriez de créer
un statut du bailleur privé qui soit
unique qui soit pérenne et qui
s'appliquent à tous les types
d'investissement c'est à dire quel que
soit son emplacement et on ne tiendrait
plus compte des zonages
quel que soit sa destination
c'est-à-dire que l'investissement
locatif porte sur une résidence
principale sur une résidence de location
longue durée et enfin quelle que soit le
type de logement qu'il s'agisse d'un
logement neuf ou ancien donc voilà
j'aimerais connaître votre idée sur les
logements intermédiaires vous n'avez pas
parlé mais dans des territoires tendus
par exemple comme le mien même si les
efforts doivent continuer à se porter
essentiellement et majoritairement sur
la production de logements sociaux pour
autant les logements intermédiaires sont
extrêmement importants parce que ils
permettent aujourd'hui à des classes
moyennes de pouvoir se loger dans nos
villes alors que sans cette possibilité
d'offrir ce type de logement et bien les
classes moyennes qui ne peuvent pas
accéder à des logements sociaux qui
parfois ne peuvent pas aussi accéder à
de la l'accession à la propriété peuvent
trouver une solution de logement à
travers les logements intermédiaires
donc est-ce que vous vous êtes favorable
bien sûr à continuer à augmenter leur
développement plus particulièrement dans
les zones tendues vous n'avez pas parlé
non plus de l'accession à la propriété
qui est absolument indispensable si on
veut quand même travailler sur tous les
segments du logement et faire en sorte
que le parcours résidentiel puisse bien
fonctionner et là aussi dans les zones
tendues pour justement permettre cette
accession donc appris maîtrisée
certains territoires l'exemple du
territoire de la métropole discoth Côte
d'Azur mais c'est pas le seul on a mis
en place des chartes des chartes
promoteurs bailleurs sociaux et
intercommunalité éventuellement commune
des chartes qui visent à encadrer autant
que faire ce peu les prix de des
opérations en accession sociale ou en
accession à la propriété à maîtriser
mais également et ça marche quand même
ça marche parce que ça permet de réguler
un marché du logement des prix du
logement qui de toute façon
malheureusement dans les zones tendues
ne se régule pas naturellement
preuve que ces chartes elles n'ont pas
d'assises légales elles sont parfois
contestées
et pour autant elles ont quand même une
démarche qui est vertueuse en
particulier dans les zones tendues
est-ce que voilà ce que vous aurez vous
conduisiez une réflexion qui vise quand
même aujourd'hui à faire en sorte que
ces chartes promoteurs constructeurs
opérateurs sociaux puissent bénéficier
demain d'une assise légale qui leur
permettent de moins être potentiellement
attaqué ou d'embarquer tout le monde
dans ces objectifs et dernier point
parce que j'ai bien conscience d'avoir
été trop longue je suis sur la politique
de la ville moi j'étais alerté par la
sous-préfète à la ville la semaine
dernière qui a reçu effectivement donc
les retours de mais la concertation qui
doit être lancée me dit-elle elle
devrait arriver plus tôt pendant l'été
et j'attire votre attention sur le fait
que une concertation qui arriverait
pendant l'été dans nos quartiers
elle serait voilà pour le moins peu
efficiente parce que c'est pas là où on
va forcément dans ces périodes là avoir
les habitants pour justement les les
mettre en mettre en oeuvre cette
concertation enfin sceller pour elle
dans le calendrier qui a été préétabli
ça ferait une concertation un petit peu
loin dans le temps et en tout cas un
moment où dans nos quartiers ce serait
susceptible d'avoir moins d'habitants
les printemps des quartiers donc je
pense qu'il y a une incompréhension avec
la sous-préfet bon je reviendrai vers
elle à ce sujet climatique voilà j'en ai
terminé merci merci beaucoup cher
Dominique la parole est à notre collègue
Bernard buis sénateur de la Drôme merci
madame la Présidente merci monsieur le
ministre pour vos propos introductifs
clairs et précis moi j'aurais deux
questions la première porte sur le bonus
au maire engagé que proposera le conseil
de la refondation logement parmi les
propositions envisagées par le CNR
logement celle sur les mers à
particulièrement retenu mon attention
comme vous le savez assurer le maintien
ou le développement d'une dynamique
urbaine fait partie de la mission des
élus qui peuvent améliorer le cadre de
vie de leurs administrés même si la
production de logements peut-être perçue
comme une charge financière elle
rapporte cependant finance publique via
les droits de mutation bien sûr et
surtout la TVA dans les taux varient de
5,5 à 20%. afin d'organiser une
émulation entre élu le CNR logement
proposera la création d'une aide
forfaitaire d'un montant calculer sur
une moyenne de logements construit et ou
transformée à condition qu'ils aient été
vides auparavant et que ces travaux les
remettent sur le marché au cours des
trois aussi dernières années le montant
de l'aide pourrait s'accroître avec le
caractère social du logement produit
sauf dans les communes carencées que
pensez-vous de cette proposition ma
deuxième question porte sur les
copropriétés dégradées monsieur le
ministre le 15 décembre dernier un
incendie a tué 10 personnes dans une
copropriété située dans la commune de
Vaulx-en-Velin en tant qu'entien maire
riche de votre expérience passée vous
êtes particulièrement impliqué sur ce
sujet des copropriétés dégradées qui
touchent d'autant plus nos quartiers en
politique de la ville pouvez-vous nous
indiquer sous compter faire ce sujet je
vous remercie
merci merci beaucoup cher Bernard
monsieur le ministre
merci donc je redis à Dominique je on va
refaire un point avec l'ensemble des
préfets l'objectif c'est que la
concertation s'engage dès maintenant à
la fois la concertation sur le zonage et
la concertation sur le les thématiques
retenues dans dans le quartier et bien
évidemment même s'il y a commission
ou des membres de la Commission soit
présent un soir dans ce quartier pour
lancer le travail donc j'étais hier dans
le Nord ils allaient lancer un certain
nombre d'aquaton thématique autour de la
politique de la ville donc la
concertation démarre ou a démarré sans
problème il faut surtout pas attendre
l'été ça n'aurait aucun sens sur sur les
autres les autres sujets oui le petit
bruit de fond qui dit il y a 2 millions
de logements vacants dans ce pays il y a
2 millions de demandeurs de logement je
l'entends aussi c'est un bruit de fond
qui n'a aucun sens enfin on va les gens
habitent essentiellement là où il y a de
l'emploi donc oui il faut construire il
faut construire tout type de logement
notamment en zone tendue mais bien sûr
pas seulement
et donc comme je le disais essayer de
redonner le goût de construire moi je
crois comme vous
aux aoah parce que ça permet de cadrer
la réflexion du logement et les aouaches
je crois seront aussi au cœur de nos
réflexions sur la décentralisation des
politiques de logement là où cette
dimension est prise en compte par
l'intercommunalité la métropole et il y
a cette vision de planification de la
politique du logement et d'une volonté
organisatrice je pense que dans les
échanges qui sont les nôtres avec
l'association d'élus très probablement
il y aura contractualisation
expérimentation et pas forcément
décentralisation pour décentraliser
l'objectif de la décentralisation c'est
justement de répondre et essayer de
lutter contre cette urgence et cette
future bombe sociale donc là où il y a
une volonté politique de construire de
construire plus de construire pour le
plus grand nombre évidemment on
l'accompagnera après
sur la proposition des offices et de
Marcel Rougemont et donc de vous-même
madame la sénatrice
il y a actuellement une réflexion qui
est en cours de la nouvelle convention
quinquennale avec Action Logement bien
évidemment le sujet de la paix est
important le sujet du snap est un sujet
extrêmement important sur lequel il
reste encore beaucoup de travail à faire
ce qui est certain c'est que ces
objectifs de construction doivent être
en lien avec les besoins et
l'accompagnement du snap qui est
d'ailleurs déjà largement décentralisé
doit nous permettre de
d'accompagner les bailleurs sociaux qui
souhaitent construire avec avec des
aides tant des aides sur la
réhabilitation que des aides sur la
construction aller
aujourd'hui dans le cadre des échanges
qui sont les nôtres avec Action Logement
jusqu'au bout de cette proposition
permettez-moi de dire que je n'en suis
pas sûr mais mais elle a le mérite de
faire réfléchir et et bouger les choses
les logements intermédiaires bien
évidemment
c'est fait partie du parcours
résidentiel et j'en suis intimement
persuadé comme vous j'essaye de me
décrire plus comme le ministre du
parcours résidentiel que le ministre du
Logement et oui le logement
intermédiaire répond à un besoin il faut
continuer l'augmentation de la
production
j'en parlais notamment avec Anne-sophie
grave et qui est la directrice de la
Caisse des Dépôts habitat et qui est un
des acteurs de cette production du
logement intermédiaire
avec une ligne donc on va continuer à
accompagner parce que ça correspond à un
besoin c'est souvent en plus pour ce que
j'ai visité des beaux produits et
il est important qu'il le reste pour
construire le parcours résidentiel sur
le statut du bailleur privé c'est un
sujet extrêmement important c'est un oui
de principe de ma part on c'est une
proposition du CNR il y a déjà le statut
du loi en meublé qui est intéressant et
je pense effectivement que que cette
réflexion doit nous permettre
d'uniformiser un certain nombre de de
propositions
lui donner de la visibilité travail
voire quelles sont les le statut doit
être vertueux donc sur la qualité du
logement sur le loyer tel qu'il sera
proposé par ce qui obtiendront ce statut
est-ce que l'aide fiscale est liée à
l'amortissement ou plus globalement
c'est encore des chantiers qui qui sont
les nôtres quels sont les
il faut il faut faire attention que ça
n'est pas un des effets inverse c'est à
dire que si on travaille sur le loyer
que le propriétaire ne fasse pas des
des mouvements vers une hausse des
charges tout ça tout ça demande
un travail à ce stade
on est il y a pas de raison de le
limiter au neuf notamment dans notre
volonté de de faire disparaître les
passoires thermiques je pense que ce
statut doit être aussi vertueux et
accompagné la rénovation alors on
parlait tout à l'heure des des
la nécessité de construire du neuf elle
est vraie la réalité quand même c'est
que 80% des logements de 2050 existent
déjà donc il faut aussi se concentrer
sur la rénovation de l'existant c'est
une priorité et il faudra la il faudra
la tenir la tenir intelligemment sans
faire sortir dans dans la situation qui
est la nôtre trop ou du logement du parc
social ou du parc locatif
accessible donc c'est ça qu'il faut
tenir en même temps si j'ose dire
la rénovation ne pas perdre trop de
logements parce que notre pays n'en a
pas les moyens mais les propriétaires
qui touchent vous voyez connaissent le
calendrier
il faut
être vertueux et qu'il le soit aussi
dans les aides il faut pas accepter et
on essaye de s'en prémunir c'est pas
simple qu'un certain nombre de logements
passentoirs bascule d'un seul coup comme
par magie dans des meublés touristiques
et ça ça serait insupportable bien
évidemment et on essaye de trouver le le
biais législatif pour pour y arriver
donc voilà on est on est en train de
travailler et y compris ceux qui ont
travaillé sur sur le CNR
l'accession à la propriété bien
évidemment
dans le cadre de cette notion de
parcours résidentiel elle est très
importante il y a pas
de graduation dans ma vision de ce qui
est bon dans un parcours résidentiel et
il faut aujourd'hui dans la crise
qu'elle a notre vous le savez la
promotion immobilière attire notre
attention hier Olivier Salleron et la
Fédération française du bâtiment faisait
une conférence de presse qui qui
attirait qui tirait la sonnette d'alarme
sur les effets de la baisse de la vente
en gros janvier février 2023 c'est 40
42% de ventes en moins que janvier
février 2022 qui était déjà pas une très
bonne année quand je suis devenu
ministre les promoteurs venaient me voir
en me disant c'est une catastrophe on a
une crise de l'offre on n'a pas assez de
logement à vendre et aujourd'hui on est
sur une crise de la demande et donc il
faut la comprendre il faut travailler
sur les taux d'intérêt il faut
travailler avec les banques ce que ce
que l'on fait avec Bruno Le Maire
donner sans renvoyer des Français dans
le surendettement bien évidemment mes
données par moment peut-être une forme
de souplesse entre le d'endettement et
le reste à vivre ce que vous avez ce que
vous avez évoqué c'est un sujet qui est
qui est le nôtre moi je crois à la vertu
du prêt à taux zéro dans l'accession à
la propriété notamment pour les pour les
primo-accédants pour pour les pour les
jeunes coupes donc ça fait partie des
sujets sur lequel on travaille mais bien
évidemment avec l'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt le prêt à taux zéro coûte plus
cher
à l'État donc il va falloir qu'on
travaille là-dessus je crois aussi aux
politiques foncières au bail réel
solidaire renforcement des offices
fonciers solidaires parce que si on
arrive à déconnecter le foncier de
l'appartement on diminue le prix du du
produit de de vendre de l'appartement et
donc on permet à plus de personnes de
d'accéder à la propriété
les chartes promoteurs oui les élus en
font et elles sont parfois
à la limite on va dire de la légalité
mais c'est un outil intéressant et je
pense qu'il faut
travailler à sa construction ne pas ne
pas la en rendre un objet substitutif au
PLU bien évidemment parce que l'outil
réglementaire c'est le PLU ou le PLU
donc faut trouver l'équilibre mais
est-ce qu'il faut
légiférer ou sur les chartes promoteurs
j'ai pas d'avis à ce stade mais il faut
regarder effectivement parce que c'est
un outil que beaucoup d'élus utilisent
et de manière vertueuse pour privilégier
l'accession à leur concitoyens
avoir 15 jours de promotion pour les
habitants de sa ville enfin on l'a tous
fait ou plus ou moins fait de manière
différente et puis on est aussi dans ses
chartes attentifs à la qualité des
matériaux au mode de chauffage choisi
etc
pour ce qui est des questions de
Monsieur buiz je les ai perdu mais voilà
non
je vais retrouver
bâtisseurs pardon alors oui ça fait
partie des sujets extrêmement importants
on peut pas redonner envie de l'acte de
construire si on n'a pas une capacité à
encourager les mères alors pour l'avoir
été il faut trouver le bon équilibre
d'abord on sait que
le point mort en termes de démographie
et de nombre d'habitants dans une ville
ne se fait pas en ne construisant pas
donc
mon sentiment c'est qu'il faut aider les
maires qui bâtissent vraiment et qui
baptissent au-delà des moyennes des
années précédentes et qui font dépasser
le point mort parce que si on construit
à Clichy par exemple je sais que si je
fais 130 logements par an je n'ai pas un
habitant en plus je reste à à mes 30.000
habitants parce que il y a un
vieillissement etc donc l'aide de merde
bâtisseurs doit se concentrer sur ce qui
dépense plus d'argent donc il faut
définir avec eux un peu comme ça a été
fait dans le cadre du balance un système
vertueux qui dit bah voilà vous
produisez plus que les années de vos
cinq précédents en moyenne etc et donc
vous avez une aide donc c'est un sujet
sur lequel on travaille bien évidemment
autour de la TVA et des richesses
produites par la production de logement
pour que lorsqu'on on produit du
logement mais on a des dépenses
supplémentaires évidentes parce qu'on
aura plus d'enfants dans nos écoles on
aura besoin de plus d'équipements
publics etc et on y travaille bien
évidemment dans le cas du CNR et même
avant
et je pense que le la TVA et le bon
levier même si on peut pas faire de
vastes communicants vous le savez entre
le entre la TVA et le et le budget et
les subventions communales mais enfin je
le disais tout à l'heure ce qui a été
mis en place dans l'aide à la relance et
donc l'aide au permis attribué tel que
un certain nombre d'élus l'ont
pré-ratiqué il y a un an me paraît être
une bonne méthode
les copro oui ça reste une une
inquiétude et une priorité aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'outils existent et
au final peu de copro vont très très
bien ça reste un outil très fragile la
copropriété
et donc il faut être attentif c'est pour
ça qu'on veut revoir les règles de
gouvernance de la copropriété mais en
respectant évidemment la démocratie du
d'une d'une copropriété on y travaille
avec avec le garde des sceaux et ses
services il faut améliorer
l'accès aux aides qu'une copro soit en
Copa en Copa qu'en OPA en plante
sauvegarde voire en hors code il faut
adapter les aides et surtout rendre les
outils plus rapides la loi allure a mis
en place leur code qui est un espèce de
d'arme atomique pour régler les
problématiques des copro mais on sait
aussi que c'est pas suffisant il faut
encore entre 8 et 12 ans pour sortir une
copropriété de sa situation
donc il faut trouver des outils de
simplification il faut probablement
simplifier
euh les les les outils de d'acquisition
à travers des DUP aujourd'hui il y a
quand même beaucoup de freins les
procédures d'urgence sont trop complexes
à obtenir avec le transport du juge sur
place enfin tout un tas de procédures
qui prennent beaucoup de de temps et qui
et qui limite l'action publique parce
que pendant tout le temps et l'exemple
de Vaulx-en-Velin est un exemple
terrible pendant tout le temps de ces
procédures une copro reste une copro
tant qu'il y a deux copropriétaires pour
un peu qu'elle soit en plus sous
administration judiciaire tout ça rend
les choses encore plus complexes et pour
les gens qui habitent là
ils ne voient pas leur quotidien
s'améliorer les ascenseurs sont toujours
en panne on a tous demande toujours si
le chauffage va être remis au moment de
la saison de chauffe etc donc on
travaille
et il faut qu'on travaille avec vous les
parlementaires peut-être à des
améliorations du cadre législatif actuel
pour simplifier
simplifier les choses et et accélérer
les les processus tels qu'ils existent
ils sont bons mais aujourd'hui ne sont
pas suffisants
merci monsieur
vous avez parlé de lourdeur et de
simplification nous avions ici il y a
maintenant trois semaines je crois les
états généraux de la simplification nous
n'avons pas osé penser au stock mais
nous avons pensé aussi à une sorte de
code de bonne conduite qui consisterait
dans la fabrique de la loi à laquelle
nous participons tous être plus sobre en
matière de contraintes et d'obligation
comment nous encourage à l'être en
matière d'artificialisation le code de
l'urbanisme
a augmenté de
44%. donc ceci veut dire que la
construction comme vous l'avez dit très
justement devient plus longue plus
longue et plus complexe et c'est un code
qui n'est pas très stable puisque
certains promoteurs nous avions entendu
lors d'un d'une mission conduite par
email point trop sur la simplification
du de l'urbanie nous faisait savoir
qu'entre l'initiation d'un projet et
l'achèvement du projet
les le code et les nombres pouvaient
avoir évolué donc je pense que ce serait
aussi intéressant monsieur le ministre
pour faciliter l'effort de construction
que nous devons faire et éviter que
cette bombe
social se fragment que nous profitons de
cette période pour essayer
de d'alléger ou en tout cas de réduire
des des obligations qui n'ont pas
toujours de pertinence ou qui renchérit
le coup je passe la parole à notre ami
sénateur du gars Laurent Burgo et
ensuite nous verrons Normandie avec
Sonia de la merci Madame merci
monsieur le ministre d'avoir cité le
quartier depuis ce vin à Nîmes que vous
connaissez bien sur lequel
c'est vrai on doit dire nous allons
partir un bien travaillé encore quelques
années ou en tant que président de la
rue et moi en tant qu'adjoint ouvert
à Nîmes et sur lequel pour lequel bien
sûr vous êtes le bienvenu pour voir son
évolution mais j'avais deux questions à
vous poser revenir sur un sujet cher à
notre collègue Dominique Estrosi puisque
c'est à son initiative que le Parlement
a mis en place et le contrat de mixité
sociale
et avec un peu une expérience
gardoise monsieur le ministre est-ce que
je crois que c'est une excellente chose
pour essayer justement de travailler en
confiance entre l'État et les élus de
mettre en place aux dispositif mais il y
a-t-il eu de votre part de votre
ministère
une circulaire à la gare des préfets
parce que je veux pas vivre pendant le
département du Gard mais plus
restreindre les mers ne reçoivent plus
d'identification j'allais dire de
pénalité que forcément de dialoguer sur
un contrat de mixité sociale donc je
crois que c'est important parce que on
voit bien vous me connaissez vous savez
tout l'attachement que j'ai logement
social mais je crois qu'il faut aussi
que l'État local joue le jeu de
travailler en confiance avec les élus
locaux et non pas à méfiance
là-dessus je crois que c'est le contrat
de mixité sociale qu'a souhaité le Sénat
était un bel outil de confiance entre
l'État et les élus locaux mais il faut
aussi
simplement l'État joue également cette
confiance et ma deuxième question
monsieur Miss avec mon collègue Pascal
Martin ici présent et Guy benaroche mon
nom actuellement une mission sur
transition environnementale et
collectivités territoriales et ma
question était de savoir si dans le cas
des contrats de ville futur où on parle
beaucoup pour ceux qui ont été adjoint
politique la ville d'éducation de
jeunesse sport de culture de santé de
sécurité mais très peu d'environnement
et très peu de transition
environnementale et serait hyper un axe
fort parce que on le voit bien fait je
pense sur le contrôle de Pascal que
suite aux diverses auditions on a un
manque de formation tant de nos élus que
que de notre jeunesse et d'un des
quartiers populaires je passe des
actions sur ce domaine là serait les
bienvenus
mon problème
cher Sonia
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre quelques questions
la présidente a évoqué dans son propre
polyminaire le rapport qui portant sur
le bilan d'action cœur de ville et
petite ville de demain même si on se
situe un peu précocément pour petite
ville de demain on avait déjà mis en
évidence un certain nombre de sujets et
parmi les sujets le l'évolution possible
du
de Normandie qui est du Malraux
patrimonial sans l'aspect historique et
qualitatif de du patrimoine
et donc connaître vos l'état de vos
réflexions en matière de financement et
et
fiscal pour
comment dire donner un coup
d'accélérateur à la rénovation et à la
réhabilitation des cures de ville et
cure de Bourg pour lesquels
on sait que le logement
[Musique]
prochaines vacances importantes pour des
raisons tout simplement de
normes thermiques phoniques et
d'accessibilité et aussi des
spécificités de liens entre la case
commerciale qui en rez-de-chaussée le
logement au-dessus auquel on ne peut
accéder que par la case commerciale et
donc tout un tas d'aspects très
techniques et qui nécessitent vraiment
un accompagnement particulier et pour le
coup le fond friche ne s'applique pas
dans cette situation là mais on a besoin
de moyens si on veut pouvoir faire
évoluer les choses ma deuxième question
porte sur la politique de logement et et
Lausanne vous avez dit à juste titre
le lien étroit avec vous avez témoigné
du lundi 3 avec les élus locaux pour
pouvoir
j'allais dire appliquer le zan et
néanmoins développer une politique de
logements je mets dîner au moins parce
que
c'est pas intuitif que les deux ailles
de paires
dans ces dans ces questions
qui porte sur sur le 0 artificialisation
net qui est quand même vécu comme comme
un outil de de d'empêchement de
développement
du logement dans les dans les communes y
compris rurales peut-être surtout rural
mais pas que puisqu'il y a aussi la
question la densité urbaine qui est un
peu portée au nu et
comme étant la solution absolue à toutes
les problématiques de zan et de poétique
de logement dans les grands centres
villes or on a un problème d'adéquation
entre les trames vertébrés qu'on s'est
un peu battu pour préserver dans les
centres-villes et centre bourg et qui
vont donc un peu à rebours de la densité
urbaine pour permettre de continuités
écologiques y compris y compris dans les
grandes villes on a la question des
îlots de fraîcheur qui sont quand même
l'avenir un peu plus serein des
habitants des grands centres urbains et
donc j'aurais voulu découvrir en quoi
votre ministère c'était emparé de la
question pratico pratique du zan c'est à
dire comment on accompagne dans les
communes rurales et comment on permet
dans les villes de rester acceptable et
de d'éviter qu'elle devienne
irrespirables voilà ma troisième
question
porte sur le le DPE ce fameux diagnostic
de performance énergétique
qui a été un peu appliquée de façon
j'allais dire systématique autonome
systématique et
uniforme sur tous les logements or le
logement d'avant en 1949 qui a des des
qualités particulières notamment en
matière d'inertie et de qualité
thermique dont l'unique problème entre
guillemets et plutôt la question du toit
et des huisseries et pas du tout la
question de de mettre une isolation par
l'extérieur or le DPE c'est
des peaux mauvais isolation par
l'extérieur et ça c'est complètement la
négation de la réhabilitation
qualitative et centre-ville et Centre
Bourse donc j'aurais aimé savoir si vous
travaillez au fond cette question de
l'évolution du DPE pour qu'il
correspondent à une qualité de logement
meilleur tout en respectant
la qualité esthétique de nos logements
et je vais terminer sur la loi SRU et
les communes nouvelles c'est un peu
notre antienne avec la Présidente il y a
pas de continuité urbaine dans les dans
les communes nouvelles il y a des
communes nouvelles rurales qui sont
éligibles à l'essrues or elle est
complètement inapplicable à part
considérer qu'une des communistes
toriques va regrouper tout le logement
social je vous remercie
peut-être avant que vous
répondiez monsieur le ministre dire que
la question qui est posée par Sonia de
la propreté sur ce que j'appelle un
bâtiment du bâti patrimonial le bâti
patrimonial vous le savez bien ce n'est
pas que Chambord au Versailles on a
aujourd'hui des programmes extrêmement
intéressants de revitalisation de
centre-ville et de centre bourg très
souvent dans des dans des villes qui ont
un bâti un peu ancien qui relève souvent
du développement durable parce qu'il
correspond à une architecture faite de
matériaux locaux donc c'est assez
vertueux pour densifier ces
centres-villes et centres-bord pour
ramener du commun il faut ramener de
l'habitat or on sait que la
transformation coûte un peu d'argent et
quand même temps je pense qu'on a un
risque de dérapage
assuré et de et de catastrophes si on
fait des isolations comme on le fait
dans d'autres bâtiments et vous savez
qu'en Alsace il y a une émotion
extrêmement forte qui conduit à la
mobilisation puisque la collectivité
européenne d'Alsace conduit une
réflexion là-dessus et la commission
culture éducation du Sénat travaille sur
le sujet avec Monsieur bichu en disant
non non mais il faut qu'on fasse
attention à pas faire de catastrophe qui
en plus n'ont pas de sens quand on vient
apposer certains types de matériaux sur
d'autres ce sont des erreurs que des
professionnels du bâti ne font pas et
puis dernier point en abondance ce que
disait Sonia de la pauvreté je regarde
monsieur Adam que je suis heureuse de
revoir parce que nous l'avions
auditionné dans le cadre de la
commission spéciale d'usane alors encore
une fois il faut pas croire mais vous ne
le pensez pas que les élus sont des
grincheux des râleurs qui non non mais
on a parfois intérêt les écouter parce
que c'est vite après devenir faire des
lois pour guérir des irritants sur la
loi notre on en a fait deux que sur
sésame vous savez qu'au Sénat on est
très attentif à ça et qu'on a fait une
proposition de loi qui a beaucoup de
mérites parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on n'arrête pas d'hurler
sur le fait que pendant des années on
s'est étalé dans les champs si je puis
dire dans beaucoup de communes
périurbaines on a fait du pavillon avec
800 mètres carrés de terrain enfin voilà
bon bref c'était peut-être pas vertueux
mais à l'époque c'était comme ça et que
ça pose des questions sur le regard des
gens sur des immeubles qui parfois ne
leur donnent pas envie de rester qu'il
fuyait certains certains quartiers et
moi j'attire l'attention sur le fait que
ceux qui parait très sage aujourd'hui
c'est à dire une densification qui
parfois ne sera pas acceptable par par
les gens peut être une
erreur aussi grave socialement que celle
de l'étalement urbain et moi je nous
donne rendez-vous dans 10 ans ou dans 15
ans si on est trop
sur sur le zinc sincèrement regardez
vous le savez bien monsieur le ministre
la manière dont les mers parlent de
l'urbanisme après la covid et après le
confinement où ils ont dit que parfois
un urbanisme trop dense trop concentré
qui manquait sans doute de de confort de
cadre de vie créé de l'attention
pardonnez-moi et puis on garde la
meilleure pour la fin monsieur le
ministre après votre réponse ce sera
notre collègue de la Manche aussi
Jean-Michel Houlgate merci monsieur le
ministre
merci alors tout ça est très dense je
vais essayer d'y répondre
rapidement et puis s'il y a des
compléments à porter on vous fera des
notes
sur le contrat de mixité sociale moi je
partage et je l'ai déjà dit l'idée que
c'est un excellent outil à disposition
des collectivités pour pour réfléchir on
est en face d'évaluation du bilan
triennal
de la de la loi SRU je j'ai écrit au
Préfet il y a quelques jours je crois ou
semaine je sais plus maintenant sur sur
ce sujet là pour qu'il bien évidemment
et tout à la fois un objectif de respect
de la loi mais aussi un objectif de de
d'échange dans à la fois
échange et bienveillance en direction
des collectivités locales mais en même
temps respect de la loi et il y a près
de 400 discussions en cours aujourd'hui
de de
contrat de mixité sociale pour pour que
on est cette vision et cette
compréhension
on le voit aujourd'hui
même si ça va un peu moyen moins bien
près de la moitié du logement social
était produit dans des villes de carencé
donc on voit l'effet vertueux de la loi
et ces rues et de son maintien parce que
il faut construire plus partout et
construire du logement social et vous le
savez mais je sais qu'on partage cette
ambition le logement social c'est tout
sauf un épouvantail c'est le logement du
plus grand nombre et donc il faut
continuer à le faire et effectivement
articuler ces contrats de mixité à
l'échelle des intercommunalités pour
pour être efficace et bâtir comme vous
l'avez dit sur le sénateur Charles
Laurent un contrat de confiance
ça ne marche que comme ça je crois alors
je peux agiter un bâton pour pour battre
mais je pense plutôt que c'est pas ça
sera pas forcément le plus efficace mais
vous le savez aussi il y a quand même de
temps en temps rares de plus en plus
rares quelques élus qui ne jouent pas le
jeu et qui nous explique qu'ils n'ont
pas de foncier pour faire du logement
social mais à la première d'entre eux on
voit autre chose se construire donc
voilà il faut il faut être attentif et
le contrat de mixité sociale est un
moyen d'être attentif alors je partage
complètement l'idée et que les quartiers
populaires doivent être aussi peut-être
surtout des lieux exemplaires de la
transition écologique ça aussi été dit
par vous madame la sénatrice
c'est le sens du programme quartier
fertile que j'avais lancé quand j'étais
encore président de delan rue il y a
près de 200 fermes urbaines qui qui
existent aujourd'hui dans le cadre du
programme
quartier fertile c'est le sens du
programme quartier résilient que j'ai
lancé là quand je suis devenu ministre
avec l'idée posz covid que un certain
nombre de programmes de rénovation
urbaines pouvaient être
regarder
ça n'a jamais été le cas mais parfois on
a donné l'impression que l'enru avait un
dogme de la démolition il n'y a pas de
dogme il faut regarder la qualité du
logement etc et oui il faut avoir des
objectifs je vous l'ai dit je crois
j'étais hier au salon du bois bio sourcé
dans la construction j'ai visité le
salon bas carbone et les les
objets les immeubles en construction
dans nos quartiers populaires doivent
être aussi et peut-être surtout
exemplaires dans ces quartiers les gens
ont souvent moins de moyens donc c'est
là où il faut faire attention aux
charges faire que l'immeubles soit le
plus passif possible le plus vertueux
même si vous j'en ai j'ai pas répondu à
votre question tout à l'heure sur les
normes la R20 elle a son calendrier
il est juste on n'est pas forcé de
l'accélérer ça aussi des effets sur les
coûts mais mais c'est un bon calendrier
et il faut respecter en particulier dans
les dans les quartiers populaires et
ensuite c'est tout ce que vous avez dit
la renaturation les cours oasis
travailler différemment sur
l'espace public les parkings les petits
parkings de centre commerciaux qui sont
aujourd'hui des miroirs à chaleur dans
lequel on peut on peut réfléchir faire
des opérations à tiroirs construire de
l'autre côté du parking
la galette de commerce en
rez-de-chaussée et construire du
logement au-dessus et puis tout ça tout
ça doit être au coeur de nos réflexions
et vous avez raison les habitants des
quartiers populaires ont droit au bon au
beau et au juste peut-être encore plus
qu'ailleurs parce que si on leur apporte
pas nous collectivités locales enfin
vous collectivités locales nous état et
ils ne l'aurons pas forcément forcément
de même
action cœur de ville petite ville de
demain alors sont vraiment des priorités
ont lancé le programme
Action coeur de ville 2 avec plusieurs 5
milliards de mémoire de d'euros sur
cette action
il faut
[Musique]
la question du commerce est une question
extrêmement importante je la partage il
faut avec avec les intercommunalités la
Caisse des Dépôts probablement inventer
des des outils de portage pour pouvoir
avoir cette mutation commerciale avoir
une capacité à la fois de préserver le
commerce de par moment peut-être même se
dire il vaut mieux avoir un commerce
vide quelques mois de plus et avoir le
bon commerçant qui va tirer notre
territoire vers le haut mais ça demande
un outil de portage parce que si on n'a
pas le l'agence foncière ou l'utile
portage ou le PF qui le fait c'est pas
le rôle des EPF à priori des fois oui
quand il y a le logement au-dessus donc
c'est des choses sur lesquelles il faut
il faut continuer à travailler sur le de
Normandie mal rouge c'est plus c'était
vous aussi
sur le de Normandie il y a une une
mission d'inspection qui est en qui est
en cours avec un rapport au Parlement
dans le cas du PLF aujourd'hui c'est un
outil qui est très peu utilisé
je crois que c'est c'est vraiment très
très peu de mémoire les chiffres sont
très bas néanmoins ça c'est un outil qui
sur le enfin plus que sur le papier
d'ailleurs extrêmement vertueux
puisqu'il est tout à la fois avec des
qualités environnementales donc on va
voir le bilan de ce dispositif peut-être
que ça fait partie des choses qui seront
intégrées au statut du bailleur privé
dont on parlait tout à l'heure parce que
les outils de défiscalisation en tout
cas
compte tenu de l'état des finances
publiques qui risque de pas tous être
maintenu mais il faut qu'on regarde ceux
qui sont les plus vertueux et
contribuent à cette capacité de produire
plus de logements là où on en a le plus
besoin
sur le zan
vous êtes presque plus expert que moi
mais mais vous savez Christophe Béchu il
travaille beaucoup avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires de l'Assemblée et du
Sénat
moi je crois vraiment qu'il faut faire
du Zéro artificialisation net une
opportunité et pas un frein pas un frein
à la construction pas un frein au
développement et donc ça passe par
d'abord le respect du calendrier parce
que c'est de mettre 50 l'objectif et
c'est un objectif qui est gradué le
président de la République est la
première ministre on en parlait lors du
congrès des maires les opérations
nationales ne seront pas
les contreparties se feront à l'échelle
nationale et pas à l'échelle du
territoire moi je crois que le zan doit
se regarder sur des périmètres élargies
et je pense que c'est le c'est important
la sobriété foncière c'est une
obligation qu'on doit porter tous
ensemble mais la porter intelligemment
on peut pas dire en même temps qu'il
manque de millions de logements dans ce
pays et et ne pas regarder nos objectifs
de construction donc il faut faire avec
le déjà là mais il faut aussi continuer
à produire et travailler ensemble
merci
la présidente
juste pour finir sur les DPE
vous savez que c'est un dispositif qui a
été réformé il y a peu de temps 2000
la nouvelle méthode tient compte
normalement de la fortinière si dans le
bâtiment ancien en fonction des
processus constructifs la brique la
terre etc et doivent s'adapter sur
l'année à la fois sur le show et sur le
froid
on a les diagnostiqueurs j'ai vu les
diagnostiqueurs dans une visio
sous l'égide de la dhupp il y a une
grosse semaine pour le rappeler à leurs
obligations parce que ils sont au cœur
de la machine ils doivent faire vraiment
un travail exemplaire on peut pas
accepter qu'un même logement est des
diagnostics différents
ou que des diagnostiqueurs casse les
prix enfin tout ça n'a aucun sens un
diagnostic bien fait ça un temps et un
prix et donc on pas extrêmement
important on soutient l'expérimentation
d'un label de performance énergétique
sur le les bâtiments dit patrimoniaux
parce que là aussi il faut être attentif
on va pas on va pas faire une Ito sur du
colombage enfin
je pense qu'on est tous persuadés de de
ça surtout que comment on le fait tenir
enfin les effets de pont thermique
risque d'être plus désastreux que que
les faits recherché donc ça fait partie
des sujets avec lesquels on travaille
avec avec les DJP avec avec le CSTB et
tous ceux qui réfléchissent avec nous
la manière dont on peut rénover en
adaptant les gestes au patrimoine et là
aussi il faut on a un enjeu de filière
de formation et d'adaptation de de la
filière c'est pareil pour pour Paris on
va pas faire des iteos sur l'ensemble
des des beaux quartiers haussmanniens du
7e du sixième arrondissement ça n'aurait
aucun sens il y a aussi des processus à
l'intérieur et c'est aussi un enjeu je
pense de pour notre industrie de
réfléchir j'ai rencontré le patron de
Saint-Gobain il y a quelques semaines
sur lequel lui aussi travaille réfléchit
à abaisser l'épaisseur là on peut pas
faire par l'extérieur on peut peut-être
faire par l'intérieur enfin il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire et et à
réfléchir et je pense que notre pays et
notre industrie gagnerait aussi à être à
la pointe et pour ce qui est de
Saint-Gobain ils travaillent beaucoup et
je pense qu'on peut leur faire confiance
pour être à la hauteur du des enjeux et
du calendrier merci Monsieur alors il
nous reste cinq minutes pour la question
il a répondu nous avons promis de vous
libérer
des choses à faire aussi merci nous
allons parler certification des comptes
que des sujets merci Monsieur le
Ministre alors très rapidement peut-être
une remarque liminaire pour saluer donc
l'installation de la Commission de
participation citoyenne des des
quartiers validé donc comme vous l'avez
dit par Mohamed mechmach en sachant que
c'est un sujet extrêmement difficile
nous l'avions Françoise Gatel a dit tout
à l'heure nous avions essayé de nous
nous pencher sur ce sur cette question
puisque fin de compte les conseils
citoyens ont été créés par la loi l'ami
de 2014 donc ça fait déjà 10 ans qu'on
essaie et qu'on t'attonne un peu donc
tous mes vœux de succès j'ai deux
questions la première question on
revient un peu sur la mixité sociale
c'est à dire que en janvier dernier
l'INSEE a publié une étude qui montre
qu'entre 2004 et 2019 c'est à dire
pendant 15 ans sur l'ensemble des villes
qui ont été étudiées la mixité sociale
était en recul la part des quartiers où
les 40% d'habitants les plus aisés sont
sur représentés à augmenter de 2,1
points donc alors on va pas revenir sur
le contrat de mixité sociale mais sur
l'autre volet par contre là où
j'aimerais vous interroger c'est-à-dire
que la part des quartiers considéré
comme mixte socialement c'est-à-dire
l'on retrouve à part égale toutes les
catégories sociales à elle diminuer de
2,8 points ce phénomène a été mis en
relief d'ailleurs par un sur excellent
de Jérôme Fourquet l'archipel français
dans lequel on parle d'agentrification
d'un côté et paupérisation de l'autre
donc comment faire en sorte que les
quartiers prioritaires soient des lieux
exemplaires de la mixité sociale quelle
mesure comptez-vous mettre pour
renforcer justement cette mixité sociale
dans les quartiers prioritaires c'est
une question et puis la deuxième c'est
un peu une expérience de mère c'est vous
savez on a parlé de logement vacants
dans la boîte à outils on demande pas là
on demande pas la baguette magique ni la
prise la multiprise mais vous savez
qu'il y a des logements qui ne sont pas
dans le cas des biens s'en mètres ils ne
sont pas non plus dans le cadre des
périls graves et imminent ce sont tout
simplement des biens qui sont délaissés
par leurs propriétaires qui sont
désintéressent complètement des biens
qui sont dégradés qui sont qui sont
vacants pour lequel certains parfois il
y a même plus de fenêtres et ainsi de
suite et sur lequel les mers sont
complètement démunies il faut plus de 10
ans moi j'étais maire de Cherbourg et il
y a des immeubles sur lequel on a mis
des procédures en place alors il y a les
OPA rues il y a même les OPA RR qu'il
faut souligner mais sur lequel on a
vraiment aucune prise alors il s'agit
pas bien évidemment de spolier les
propriétaires il s'agit pas non plus de
remettre en cause le droit s'accro-saint
un gravé dans la constitution de
propriété mais on est quand même
relativement un peu en culotte courte
pour pouvoir remettre sur le marché
c'est bien qui qui dégrade complètement
l'image d'une ville alors que nous dans
les aménagements urbains on fait des
efforts conséquents
merci monsieur le sénateur vous avez
presque tout dit et la question est la
réponse
[Musique]
la mixité sociale est un enjeu et la
lutte contre l'entre-soi en est un et
l'autre soit n'est pas réservée au
quartier populaire d'une certaine
manière et encore moins enfin on le voit
tous l'entre-soi il touche aussi et
peut-être surtout ceux qui en ont les
moyens de se de se le créer moi je je
sous titre souvent mon action communiste
de la ville dire que la réussite de la
politique de la ville c'est de permettre
aux habitants des quartiers populaires à
travers l'émancipation de l'équité s'ils
en ont envie mais surtout leur donner
envie d'y rester le drame des maires de
ville populaire c'est ça c'est de voir
les populations qu'on a accompagnées et
qui vont mieux quitter la ville alors
souvent une raison liée à l'école quand
on fait les études pour comprendre
pourquoi on quitte une ville c'est
souvent l'entrée au collège notamment
mais donc pour y arriver c'est vraiment
l'enjeu de quartier 2030 c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on va permettre de transformer dans
la vision de ces quartiers de ceux qui
habitent ce que je crois plus à la
mixité sociale de ceux qui sont déjà là
que de ce peu d'habitants du 7e
arrondissement vont se réveiller un
matin en disant qu'est-ce que j'ai envie
de venir habiter à Clichy-sous-Bois je
me fais guère d'illusions ou dans un
certain nombre de d'autres territoires
mais par contre qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour que les habitants des quartiers
populaires à travers l'amélioration de
la mobilité de la qualité de leur
logement de l'accès à l'emploi de
l'école dans laquelle ils vont mettre
leurs enfants
l'accès aux sports à la crèche etc leur
donne envie de rester et parce que la
vie associative est suffisamment riche
donc c'est ça l'enjeu c'est ce qu'on
essaye de construire à travers quartiers
2030 je n'ai pas de recette magique et
je pense que aucun de mes processeurs
dans le nom et les élus locaux que vous
êtes maire ou élus vous le savez c'est
extrêmement difficile
on le voit à travers les différents
classements des lycées etc
à quel point la question de l'école est
centrale je n'en suis persuadé
la question de
l'attractivité du métier d'enseignant la
question que le ministre éducation
nationale prend à bras le corps du
remplacement
des profs et des absences je crois
vraiment que l'école de joue un rôle
central sur cette question parce que
parce que la mixité ou l'absence de
mixité sociale dans le quartier se voit
dans l'école l'absence de mixité sociale
de mixité scolaire et ça fait partie des
raisons pour lesquelles nos concitoyens
quittent parfois leur quartier mais pas
seulement la question de la tranquillité
dans les dans les quartiers évidemment
une question extrêmement importante qui
fera que les gens aient envie d'y rester
ou d'y venir et la qualité du logement
enfin c'est tout ça qu'il faut je pense
que l'âme
le propre de la politique de la ville
c'est d'être elle a encore je veux pas
être dans le café du commerce mais être
en capacité de tenir vraiment en même
temps les questions urbaines et les
questions humaines l'urbain et l'humain
en même temps ce qui a souvent manqué
dans l'histoire des 40 ans de la
politique de la ville c'est qu'on a pas
su faire les deux vraiment en même temps
à l'époque du Développement social des
quartiers dans les années 90 on a mis
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent pour soutenir
les associations et c'était très bien et
puis il y a eu les grands projets de
ville puis il y a eu le séisme Borlo
séisme positif de de l'enru du des
contrats enfin des programmes en rue de
2004 et là on a mis beaucoup l'accent
sur sur l'urbain et un peu moins sur
l'humain là moi mon objectif c'est
vraiment de tenir les deux en même temps
pour justement construire cette ville
dans lequel il fait bon vivre dans
lequel les femmes se sentent
tranquille dans leur dans leur vie
quotidienne dans leur accès à l'emploi
dans lequel on travaille sur
l'émancipation des jeunes filles dans
leur dans leur choix d'orientation enfin
toutes ces questions que vous connaissez
aussi bien que moi mais qui me
paraissent absolument nécessaire dans
dans l'envie d'y rester
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour
le temps que vous nous avez consacré et
merci pour l'intensité la qualité de nos
échanges pour un sujet vous l'avez dit
qui au coeur de ce qu'anim tout élu
c'est le bien-être entre guillemets de
chacun de nos concitoyens l'égalité des
chances la capacité d'insertion et
d'émancipation mais aussi la cohésion
sociale merci beaucoup monsieur minet
merci
nous sommes passionnants
c'est un peu notre ADN on est heureux
quand on le reconnaît